ABOUT ECONOMICS I WOULD BE
VERY COMAD.
THANK YOU THAT'S
INTERESTING.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>> Tucker: HUGE PERCENTAGE
OF WHAT YOU HEAR ON TVS
THESE DAYS CENTERS ON THE
PAYROLLS OF
PEYROLLS OF
PERIOLLS OF
PERILSLS OF
PERILSOF OF
PERILSOF RF
PERILSOF RUSSIA.
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND OUR PR PARTY HAVE BEEN
TELLING US FOR NOR ARE MORE
THAN A YEAR.
IS THIS TRUE?
LET'S PLAY A GAME AND YOU
DECIDE.
WE WILL DESCRIBE ACTIONS BY
A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER AND
YOU GUESS WHETHER IT'S
RUSSIA OR CHINA.
GET A PEN.
READY?
FIRST, THE FBI DIRECTOR SAID
THIS COUNTRY USES STUDENTS
AND PROFESSORS AT AMERICAN
UNIVERSITIES AS SPIES.
THIS PROBLEM IS SO
WIDESPREAD THAT ALMOST EVERY
FBI FIELD OFFICE IS DEALING
WITH IT RUSSIA, NOPE.
CHINA?
CHINA HAS 350,000 STUDENTS
IN THE U.S.
SOME OF WHOM APPARENTLY ARE
INTELLIGENCE AGENTS.
NEXT QUESTION, THIS QUESTION
REPORTEDLY HACKED THE OFFICE
OF PERSONNEL MANAGEMENT,
GIVING IT ACCESS TO MILLIONS
OF FEDERAL PERSONNEL RECORDS
WHICH ALLOWS ITS SPY AGENT
TO LOCATE ESPIONAGE TARGET.
THIS COUNTRY HACKED THE FDIC
AND OTHER AGENCIES.
RUSSIA?
NO.
CHINA.
A COMPANY FROM THIS COUNTRY
HAS EFFECTIVELY TAKEN OVER
AN ENTIRE U.S. TERRITORY.
BLOOMBERG REPORTED LAST WEEK
HOW A MASSIVE STATE
SPONSORED GAMBLING RUNS THE
ISLAND OF SIGH PAN WHICH
USED TO BE OURS?
RICKENBACKER?
NO CHINA ONCE AGAIN.
THE COUNTRY WILL OVERTAKE
THE U.S. AS WORLD'S LARGEST
ECONOMY?
RUSSIA?
PLEASE, THAT'S HILARIOUS.
RUSSIA IS THIRD W0R8D
COMPARED TO YES, CHINA.
THIS COUNTRY HAS KILLED TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS BY
MANUFACTURING AND EXPORTING
FENTANYL DEADLIEST NARCOTIC
KNOWN TO MAN.
RUSH HAY HAVE FAKE TWITTER
ACCOUNTS BUT CHINA DID THAT
THIS COUNTRY DEMANDS CENSOR
PRODUCTS OLIGARCHY THAT RUNS
POLICE STATE.
AMAZINGLY AMERICAN COMPANIES
OBEDIENTLY COMPLY WITH THESE
ORDERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
AFRAID NOT TO.
IS IT RUSSIA THEY ARE COW
TAILING TOO MEAN OLD PUTIN?
OF COURSE NOT, IT'S CHINA.
STRIKES YOU AS A BIGGER
THREAT TO AMERICA?
THE AUTHOR OF CHINESE GIRL
IN THE GHETTO FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY
PRO-TRUMP PAC JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
COUPLE LEVELS, I ONE
THINK -- RISE OF CHINA IS A
THREAT TO A PLACE IN OUR
WORLD.
BUT COMPARED TO RUSSIA, IS
THERE REALLY A COMPARISON?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, LET'S
RECALL THAT A FEW YEARS AGO
SENATOR JOHN MCCAIN WHO SAID
THAT RUSSIA REALLY IS JUST A
GAS STATION MASQUERADING AS
A COUNTRY.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T NEED
TO TAKE THAT LITERALLY, BUT,
I THINK ANY SANE PERSON
WOULD LOOK AT CHINA'S
ECONOMY, LOOK AT THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR RISE,
AND UNDERSTAND THAT CHINA
ACTUALLY POSES A MUCH MORE
SERIOUS LONG TERM STRATEGIC
THREAD TO AMERICA'S PLACE IN
THE WORLD.
BUT WE DON'T EACH HAVE TO
LOOK AT THAT ON SUCH BROAD
SCALE, I THINK WE JUST NEED
TO LOOK BACK 20 YEARS.
THE LAST TIME WE HAD A
SERIOUS FOREIGN INFLUENCE
CAMPAIGN SCANDAL IN THIS
COUNTRY WAS DURING THE
CLINTON ERA WHEN, YOU KNOW,
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE WAS FORCED TO GIVE
BACK NEARLY $3 MILLION OF
FOREIGN MONEY AND WE KNOW
THAT.
>> Tucker: RUSSIAN MONEY?
>> AND WE KNOW THAT DURING
THAT SCANDAL THERE WAS
ACTUALLY A LOT OF CHINESE
MONEY INVOLVED.
MONEY FROM THE COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENT OR PEOPLE
AFFILIATED WITH THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND THERE WAS
MONEY FROM ELSEWHERE IN
ASIA, TOO.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY REAL MONEY
THAT HAD TO BE GIVEN BACK.
THUS FAR WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN THE
CURRENT RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: IS IT POSSIBLE IF
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO HAS
POWER YOU JUST ASK WHO DOES
NOBODY CRITICIZE?
EVERYBODY CRITICIZE RUSSIA,
THERE ARE NO REPERCUSSIONS.
ASES AS A SINGLE PERSON IN
HOLLYWOOD OR FINANCE EVER
CRITICIZED CHINA.
DOESN'T THAT TELL YOU HOW
BEHOLDEN WE TORE KAHNE.
WHAT A THREAT THEY ACTUALLY
ARE.
NOBODY SAYS ANYTHING?
>> SOME PEOPLE HAVE
CRITICIZED CHINA WHEN IT WAS
POPULAR TO COULD SO.
LET'S REMEMBER SEVEN YEARS
IN TIBET DONE BY BRAD PITT.
POPULAR BACK THEN TO CREDIT
SIZE.
>> Tucker: COULD THAT GET
MADE TODAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
HOLLYWOOD HASN'T COME AND
ASKED ME FOR MY OPINION.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Tucker: RICHARD GERE
CAN'T GET A MOVIE ROLE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
A LOT OF THESE HOLLYWOOD
PEOPLE LIKE TO DO THINGS.
THESE DAYS IT IS POPULAR TO
QUESTION DONALD TRUMP IT IS
POPULAR TO QUESTION THE
LEGITIMACY OF ELECTORAL
VICTORY.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE OBSESSED
WITH THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
PEOPLE FROM THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA.
WHAT THEY REALLY WANT TO DO
IS ESSENTIALLY TO SORT OF
BRING OUT ANYTHING THAT
MAKES THE CURRENT PRESIDENT
LOOK BAD.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, LOOK, I
THINK IT'S OKAY TO CRITICIZE
THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE CRITICIZED MANY
PRESIDENTS AND REALLY MEANT
IT.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY, HAVE YOU THOUGH
ABOUT SOBERLY WHAT THREATS
IT FACES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE
TELLING BIGGEST THREAT IT
FACES EITHER LYING OR
STUPID.
>> OR YOU COULD BE BOTH,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU COULD
BE BOTH.
>> WHAT WE DO KNOW WHILE WE
HAVE BEEN OBSESSING OVER
THIS RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY IGNORED
SOME REALLY WEIGHTY ISSUES.
NOT JUST CHINA BUT CHINA
BEING ONE THE MOST WEIGHTY
ISSUES AMONG THEM.
>> Tucker: IT'S A REALLY
GOOD POINT.